franchement Béatrice n'avait pas changé
non mais franchement non mais sans
déconner regardez
[Applaudissements]
là
j'étais plus
elle est pas là pareil c'est incroyable
ou pas alors autre personne qui n'a pas
changé c'est Gilles Verdez regardez ado
regardez le ado ah bon pas de bol
ça c'était juste avant en fait j'entrais
l'accusé
généralement quand tu as une photo comme
ça tu es comme ça tu es normalement il
est quand même il est dedans
[Rires]
a commencé très vite par se faire
remarquer de larcin en petit larcin il a
d'abord volé une Renault 18
[Musique]
les autorités n'arrêtent il dit non ce
n'est pas moi c'est Fatou
très vite Gilles Verdez se fait
remarquer par sa chevelure on l'appelle
très vite
les talons de Bretagne
mais ces pull se pull tu l'avais
vraiment
[Applaudissements]
je t'explique Juliette quand il était en
CM2 les gars le premier pour le prof non
mais je te dis non mais frère là j'ai 17
ans c'est la photo du permis que j'avais
gardé j'ai dit ça je peux dire un truc
oui et je pense vraiment je pense qu'il
avait une petite toco il avait une
petite Toko il avait franchement Gilou
c'est quoi je trouve qu'il y a quelque
chose c'est gentil et je pense que tu es
une petite Toko vraiment
je l'ai gardé pour le permis à 18 ans et
en fait là j'avais coupé mes cheveux qui
m'arrivaient en bas en haut des fesses
et très bien très bien chez les hippies
c'était pas un hippie comme ça c'est un
vrai voilà voilà
il a un beau village et en fait je les
ai coupés pour aller à l'armée et je
voulais pas paraître trop bizarre et dès
qu'ils m'ont vu ils m'ont réformé P4
tout de suite
et donc après tu as laissé tes cheveux
après j'ai laissé pousser les cheveux
elle pénis toi et vous faites de
l'humour ou pas du tout il y a un petit
truc il y a un petit truc je suis désolé
on peut avoir quelque chose de cette
petite frange je m'appelle une
frangipane
j'aime pas me vanter mais j'arrivais
régulièrement j'étais hippie donc
j'allais à Amsterdam j'arrivais à la
gare d'Amsterdam je peux vous dire que
je sortais de la gare j'avais 5 filles
autour de moi
[Rires]
c'est surtout la ville où il y a le plus
de professionnels
[Musique]
de la guitare et ben ce serait encore
mieux passé tu vois
malheureusement il joue de rien
tu joues beaucoup de pipeau
là tu es pas mal
on dirait Samir Nasri le kiki de tous
les kiki
il est mignon tu as quel âge a
impressionnante que j'ai pas de bêtises
combien 16 ou 17 un peu jeune mais tu es
mignon alors on passe on va on va pas ah
bah non merde alors là attention
attention les chéris c'est en noir et
blanc non mais sans rien c'est Daniel
c'est Daniel mettait la photo en noir et
blanc regardez Daniel
[Applaudissements]
les gars Daniel on commence tous à se
poser des questions je suis désolé
il y a une Panhard c'est une marque qui
n'existe plus de voiture quand même
c'est quand même
une voiture comme ça tout là-bas c'est
une marque qui existe
allez on a Géraldine maillet Géraldine
17 ans
un petit peu
avec ma maman là tu avais la TECO arrête
j'en ai une autre de Géraldine elle est
magnifique
[Applaudissements]
d'une seconde parce que si ça vous
intéresse que je parle de moi bien sûr
j'ai montré à mon psy et il m'a dit ce
regard très ouvert comme ça avec les
yeux vers le haut sur le monde ça
montrait l'ambition la curiosité et la
réussite et tous et tout est arrivé
[Rires]
ta meuf ah il y a Delphine bah elle a
pas changé
le dernier shooting que j'ai fait que ma
meilleure amie on allait dans une petite
maisonnette et on s'est fait des photos
comme ça entre nous c'est la première
fois que je voilà
entre filles alors c'est vrai que tu as
un regard
je voulais pas le dire mais tu as un
regard espier avec les espiègle un peu
non mais voilà on s'est fait un petit
délire on s'est fait un petit shooting
voilà alors regardez Bernard Montiel il
avait déjà mis long adolescent regardez
non mais sans déconner le gars et là il
était adolescent frère on dirait qu'il a
45 ans
maintenant
Bernard tu as toujours été beau tu
resteras beau non non mais là j'avais 18
ans il se charge il est tellement humour
rabot tu mourras beau c'est pharook non
c'est un berger des Pyrénées
ah oui ah oui oh là là
[Applaudissements]
sur le rap sur Radio Laser vous savez ce
que c'était mon blaze d'animateur
c'était Guigui la peufra ah
les bons souvenirs et alors ils ont même
pas je sais même pas d'où ils ont eu
cette photo ils ont sorti une photo de
toi alors moi c'est sobre classe
vraiment sobre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
c'est même pas les chaussettes et les
cheveux
crois-moi parce que je savais pas
qu'elle allait passer dans l'émission à
la tour c'est quand même pas mal
non mais c'est quand même et même moi
c'est même pas
de soleil
aujourd'hui tu es tourné vers l'autre
mais à l'époque
[Applaudissements]